the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I want to start a new topic
circuits no no that's good that's good
circuits are good thank you thank you
much better so just to provide some
perspective I want to remind you where
we are how we got here and where we're
going so at the beginning of the course
we promised that there were several
intellectual themes that we would talk
about probably the most important one
there is designing complex systems
that's what we're really about we would
like you to be able to make very
complicated systems how do you think
about parts how do you think about
connecting them how do you think about
things when you want to make something
that's very complicated part of that is
modeling we just finished a module on
modeling so in order to make a complex
system we'd like to be able to predict
how it will behave before we completely
build it sometimes it's impossible to
build the entire system before sometimes
it's impossible to build prototypes
sometimes you're stuck with going with
the with the design at launch and
figuring out how it works in those cases
in specific it's very important to be
able to model it to have some confidence
that the things going to work we're
going to talk about augmenting physical
systems with computation that's the
module we're about to begin
and we'll conclude by talking about how
to build systems that are robust to
change so we started with the idea of
how do you make complicated systems and
we introduced this notion of primitives
combination abstraction and pattern in
terms of software engineering we did
that because that's the simplest
possible way of getting started it
provided a very good example at the low
level by thinking about Python by
thinking about the primitive structures
that Python gives you how those can be
combined how you can abstract how you
can recognize patterns but then we also
built a higher level abstraction we
was the state machine idea there the
idea was you didn't have to have state
machines in order to build the brain for
a robot but it actually turns out to be
easy if you do because there's a
modularity there you can figure out if
each part works independent of the other
parts and then you can be pretty sure
when you put it together the whole
thing's going to work so that was kind
of our introduction to this notion of
pcap then we went on to think about
signals and systems and that was kind of
our introduction to modeling how do you
make a model of something that predicts
behavior so we transitioned from
thinking about how do you structure a
design to how do you think about
behavior today we're going to start the
thing about circuits circuits are really
going to a more primitive physical layer
how do you think about actually making a
device so the device that we'll think
about is a thing to augment the
capabilities the sensor capabilities of
the robot will think about making a
light tracking system and the idea is
going to be that you'll build a head the
head has a neck so you have to control
the neck the head has eyes it will mount
on top of the robot and that'll let you
drive the robot around looking for a
light and you'll do that by designing a
circuit so that's kind of the game plan
for the next three weeks so today what I
want to do is introduce the notion of
circuits introduce the theory for how we
think about circuits and then in the two
labs this week the idea will be to
become familiar with the practice of
circuits how do you actually build
something how do you actually make
something work so today's the theory so
the theory the idea in circuits is to
think about a physical system as the
interconnection of parts and rules the
connect them in fact the rules fall into
two categories we're going to think
about the currents that go through parts
and the voltage that develops across
parts and we'll see that there's a way
of thinking about the behavior
the entire circuit that integrates all
of those three pieces how does the part
work how do the currents that go in
through the part work and how do the
voltages that are produced across the
part how do they work so I'll just start
with two very simple examples the first
is the most trivial example you can
think about you can think about a
flashlight as a circuit you closed the
switch current flows very simple idea we
will make a model of that that looks
like this we'll think about the battery
being a source in this case a voltage
source we'll think about the light bulb
being a resistor we will have two parts
we'll have to know the current voltage
relationships for both of the parts and
we'll have to know the ramifications for
those currents and voltages when you put
them together very very simple the other
simple example that I want to illustrate
is this idea of a leaky tank here the
idea that I want to get across is that
the circuit idea is quite general what
we talked about circuits we almost
always talk about electronic circuits
but the theory is by no means limited to
electronics so for example well if we
think about a leaky tank we think about
a pipe spewing water into a reservoir
maybe that's the Cambridge reservoir
maybe that's the water coming out of the
Reuben reservoir maybe that's the demand
put on by the Cambridge people trying to
take showers in the morning
I don't know but so we think about flow
into a tank a reservoir and flow out and
we can make a model for that in terms of
a circuit in the circuit there are
through variables and across variables
in an electronic circuit the through
variable is current here the through
variable is the flow rate so it's the
flow of water in and the flow of water
out represented here by these things
that look like currents and the across
variable for an electronic device is
voltage the across variable for this
kind of a fluidic device the across
variable is pressure so we think of as
this thing gets ahead of that thing as
there's more stuff coming in than going
out the height goes up and the pressure
bill
mmm same idea so the point is that we'll
develop the theory for circuits in terms
of electronics but you should keep in
the back of your mind that it's a lot
more general idea than just electronics
in fact there are two completely
distinct reasons why we even bother with
circuits one is that they're very
important to physical systems if you're
designing a power network of course you
have to think about the way the power
network the power grid works as a
circuit that's obvious in electronics of
course if you're gonna build a cellphone
you have to know how the parts
interconnect electronically that's
obvious but probably the biggest use for
circuits these days is not those
applications although those are very
important circuits are also used as
models of things so well many models for
complex behaviors are in fact circuit
models so in terms of electronics the
idea is that we want to get on top of
electronics we want to understand how
circuits work so we can understand
things like that if you look at how
complex processors have got over my
professional life we start with my
professional life down at about a
thousand transistors per processor and
today were up at about a billion that's
enormous even in the stone Age's
when we were designing things that had a
thousand parts we still had trouble
thinking about those thousand parts all
at once we still need pcap we still
needed ways of combining the activities
of many things into a conceptual unit
that was bigger here it's just
impossible if you don't have that so
that's one of the reasons we study
circuits and the other reason is here so
here I'm sharing a model for the way a
nerve cell works this model is taken
from 602 one the idea this comes from
the study of the hodgkin-huxley model
for neural can
Chenin arguably the most successful
mathematical theory in biophysics which
explains the completely non-trivial
relationship between how the parts from
biology works and the behavior in terms
of propagated action potentials works so
the idea is that we understand how this
biological system works because we think
about it in terms of a circuit that's
the only successful way we have to think
about that so what I want to do then is
spend today figuring out circuits at the
very most primitive level the level of
that I'm going to talk about in terms of
circuits is roughly analogous to the
level that we talked about with Python
when we were thinking about how Python
provides utilities for primitives
combinations abstractions and patterns
so I'm going to start at the very lowest
level and think about what are the basic
primitives the smallest units will ever
think about in terms of circuits and
what are the rules by which we combine
them so I'll start with the very
simplest ideas the very simplest
elements we will oversimplify things and
think about the very simplest kind of
electronic elements as resistors that
obey Ohm's law V equals IR voltage
sources things that maintain a constant
voltage regardless of what you do and
current sources things that maintain a
constant current regardless of what you
do these things are as I said analogous
to the primitive things that we looked
at in Python they're also analogous to
the primitive things that we looked at
in system functions can somebody think
of when we were doing difference
equations what were the primitives that
we started with when we started to study
difference equations what's the most
primitive elements that we thought about
delay yeah so we thought about things
like so we had delay anything else game
anything else so we had exactly three
primitives and we got pretty far with
those three primitives we learned the
rules for interconnection right we
didn't really make a big deal out of it
we didn't formalize it but the rules for
interconnection were something like
every node has to have exactly one
generator you can't connect the output
of this to this that's illegal
every node has to have one source and
every node can source lots of inputs
that was kind of the rules of the inter
case the interconnects here will be a
little bit more complicated so those are
the elements that we'll think about and
the first step is going to be to think
about how do they interconnect the
simplest possible interconnections are
trivial in the case of the battery you
have up the voltage source to the
resistor the voltage source makes the
voltage across the resistor one volt if
we say the resistor is 1 ohm then
there's 1 amp current period done easy
similarly if we were to hook up the the
resistor to a current source we would
get something equally easy except now
the current source would guarantee that
the current through the resistor is an
amp therefore the voltage across the
resistor by Ohm's law would be a volt so
we would end up with the same solution
for a completely different reason here
the voltage is constrained here's the
currents constrained just to make sure
everybody's with me figure out what's
the ATLA what's the current I that goes
through this resistor slightly more
complicated system take 20 seconds talk
to your neighbor figure out a number
between 1 and 5
okay so what's the answer everybody
raise your hand with the number one
through five come on come on everybody
about it come on come on you can blame
it on your neighbor that's the rules
right you talk to your neighbor then you
can blame dumb answers on your neighbor
okay about 80% correct I'd say so how do
you think about this what what's going
to be the current how would you
calculate the current what do i do first
what Luke do you want to use left side
across the resistor so the current would
be and so the source establishes this
voltage would be one that makes this
current be one that would be consistent
with the current coming out of here
except we have to also think about that
one amp source so the question is what's
the 1 amp source do nothing it's just
they're sort of for decoration or for a
few stations so that we can make a
interesting question
so where's the current more than one
resistor from this current ignore the
voltage you ever hear for the moment if
this current flowed through the resistor
then you'd have one amp going through
there and you'd have 1 volt generated by
that current which just happens to be
exactly the right voltage to match the
voltage from the voltage source so if
you think about this the voltage
guarantees that this is 1 volt but so
does the current in order to
simultaneously satisfy everything all
you need to do is have all of this
current go around and come down through
that resistor that'll generate the Volt
so there's no propensity for a more
current to flow out of the source
because the source is 1 volt and it's
facing a circuit that's already 1 volt
so the idea was to try to give you
something that's relatively simple that
you can think through on your own but
not trivial so the answer was 1 amp but
that one amp was not for the trivial
reason the 1 amp is because the current
from the from the right flows through
the resistor and makes the voltage be 1
okay so so the so the right answer is 1
but for the reason that you might not
have originally thought but more
importantly I wanted to use that as a
motivation for thinking about how do we
think about bigger circuits so when the
relate when the simple circuit like 2
parts there's no problem figuring out
what the answer is going to be wouldn't
but when the circuit has even three
parts it may require more thinking and
you may want to have a more structured
way of thinking about the solution yes
right it has been two years you can't
violate this voltage so that would have
been one volt
so that would have been one amp through
the resistor so then you're left with
the problem that this guy is pushing -
and that guy is only eating one but the
rules for the voltage source say eat or
a source however much current is is
necessary in order to make the voltage
equal to one so the excess amp goes
through the voltage source so the
voltage source is in fact being supplied
power rather than supplying power itself
had this been - am some of the power
from this source would have gone into
the resistor and some of the power from
this source would have actually gone
into the voltage source so if the
voltage source were for example a model
for a rechargeable battery that
rechargeable battery would be charging
does that make sense so if there had
been a mismatch in the conditions you
still have to satisfy all the
relationships from from all the sources
to volt then the voltage would have
required that there is two amps flowing
here one amp would come from here but
another amp would come from here this
voltage source will supply whatever
current is necessary to make its voltage
law real okay
in fact what we'll do now is turn toward
a discussion of more complicated systems
that will let you go back and in
retrospect analyze all those cases that
we just did and you'll be able to see
trivially how that has to be the right
answer so what I want to do now is
generate a formal structure for how you
would solve circuits yes
okay anything generate a current without
generating a voltage that's a tricky
question if you think about something as
generating a current then the voltage is
not necessarily determined by that part
so that's kind of illustrated here if
this guy is generating a current this
guy is not actually the person who the
the element that is controlling its own
voltage in general if you want to speak
simultaneously about the current and
voltage across the device you have to
know what it was connected to each part
we'll get to this in a moment in case
some of you are worried about launching
ahead we will cover this so this is not
this is this is very good motivation for
figuring out what's going to happen in
the next three slides so each part gets
to tell you one relationship between
voltage and current generally speaking
that's not enough to solve for voltage
and current voltage and current is like
two unknowns the ellow each element
relationship is one equation so the
current source gets to say current
equals axe current equals one amp
doesn't get to tell you what the voltage
is so being a little more physical to
try to address your question more
physically there are processes that can
be extremely well modeled as current
generators in fact many electronic
semiconductor parts like transistors
work more like a current source than
like anything else so there are devices
that behave as though they were current
sources but they don't simultaneously
get to tell you what is their current
and what is their voltage they only get
to tell you what is their current okay
so let's think about now if you had a
more complicated system
how could you systematically go about
finding the solution and as we mentioned
earlier there's something called
kirchoff's law and in fact there's two
of them here cops voltage law and
Kirchhoff's current law Kirchhoff's
voltage law in its most elementary form
says that if you trace the path around
any closed path in a circuit regardless
of what the path is every closed path
the sum of the voltage is going around
that a closed path is zero so for
example in this circuit the red the red
path illustrates one closed path through
the circuit it goes up through the
voltage source down through this
resistor and then down through that
resistor Kirika voltage law says that
some of the voltages around that loop is
zero that's written mathematically here
minus v1 for here plus v2 for here plus
v4 for here is zero okay where did the
signs come from the signs came from the
reference directions that we assigned
arbitrarily to the elements before I
ever do a circuits question I always
assign a reference direction every
voltage has a positive terminal and a
negative terminal and I must be
consistent in order to apply these rules
these rules only work if I declare a
reference direction and stick with it
if midway through a problem I flip it
I'll get the wrong answer so the minus
sign has to do with the fact that as I
trace this path I enter the minus part
of this guy but the plus part of that
guy in that guy so the the sign of v1 is
negated relative to the others a
different way to think about that is
here we can think that v1 is the sum of
v2 and v4 that's sometimes more
intuitive because you saw it started
here going through this path you would
end up with a voltage that is v1 higher
than where you started
whereas starting here you would end up
with a voltage here this v4 higher than
where you started and then by the time
you got to here it'd be V 2 plus V 4
higher than where you started you start
one place and on one root you end up V 1
higher and in the other root you get V 4
plus V 2 higher so it must be the case
that V 1 is the same as V 2 plus V 4
those are absolutely equivalent ways of
thinking about it
so those laws are equivalent if you
think about is as a path you think about
some of the paths some of the paths no
the path coinciding with the negative
direction of some of the elements and
the positive direction of others ok how
many other paths are there take 20
seconds talk to your neighbor figure out
all the possible paths for which KVL has
to apply
okay so everybody raise your hand and
show a number of fingers equal to the
number of KVL equations less - very good
virtually 100% correct why do you all
say five do we just to say seven why do
you all say seven so there's three
obvious ones I was expecting a couple of
threes right this was supposed to be
okay yeah I do plot against you I was
expecting some threes so there's three
obvious paths that are analogous to the
first one we looked at if I call the
first path a then there's B and C which
are the excursions around here and you
can write the equations just the same
they each involve three voltages and
they each go through some starting at
the negative side and some starting at
the positive side so those are in some
sense the obvious ones but there are
others too so one way to think about it
what I'd like you to do is you numerate
all the paths through the circuit I
should have said all the paths through
the circuit that go through each element
exactly each element one or fewer times
I don't want you to go through the same
element twice so here's another path
that would go through elements at most
one time so up through here over through
here which didn't go through any
elements down through that element
across that line down through here etc
and you get an equation for that here's
another here's another here's another
and if you try to think about a general
rule a general rule of something like
how many of those panels can you make
and paste together where the loop goes
through the perimeter you're not allowed
to go through an inner place because if
you went through an inner node you'd
have to go through it twice you have if
you wanted the path to go through an
inner element you'd have to go through
that end twice so in fact the answer is
seven there are seven different ways
seven different paths all of which
according to Kira cops voltage law all
of which the sum of the voltages around
those paths has to be zero the problem
is of course that those equations are
not all linearly independent so if you
just had a general purpose equation
solver and by the way we'll write one of
those in week a for solving circuits if
you just passed those seven equations
into a general purpose equation solver
it would tell you there's something awry
with your equations because they're not
linearly independent so you can however
think about linearly independent in
particularly simple cases this network
is a particular kind of network that we
call a planar network a planar network
is one that I can draw on a sheet of
paper without crossing wires so I can
draw this network without crossing wires
I'll call it planar and it turns out
that the tier cost voltage laws for the
innermost loops are always independent
of each other that's kind of obvious
because as you go to a so each loop
contains at least one element that some
other loop didn't have so that's kind of
the reasoning for why it works so if you
think about this particular loop which
we included in the seven you can think
about that as being the sum of the loops
this way the a loop and the B loop
because we write KVL for the a loop and
KVL for the B loop and add them you end
up deriving KVL for the more complicated
path and if you think about what's going
on it's not anything terribly magic this
path is the same as the a path added to
that path where I went through this
element down when I did the a path and
up when I did the Bape the B path so
those parts canceled out that was the
rule that I was talking about how I
don't really want to go through the same
element twice what I'm applying KVL so
the idea then is that there's a
systematic way and
easy way to figure out all the KVL loops
you just think about all the possible
paths through the circuit you do have to
worry about linearly independent in the
case of planar networks that's pretty
straightforward the planar networks you
can always have figure out the linearly
independent KVL equations by looking at
the smallest possible possible loops the
loops with smallest area okay so that's
half of it that's KVL the other key R
cops law is KCl Kier cops current law
there we're thinking about the flow of
current so the flow of current is
analogous to the flow of incompressible
fluid water for example if you trace the
amount of water that flows through a
pipe that goes into a Y then the sum of
the flows out has to equal the flow in
if that weren't true the water would be
building up so we think about pipes as
transporting the flow of water without
allowing it to build up anywhere that's
precisely how we think about wires in
electrical circuits the wires allow the
transport of electrons but don't allow
the build-up of electrons okay do
electrons build up sure but we don't let
we in our idealized world we say they
don't build up in the wires they build
up in a part and we'll have a special
part that allows the electrons to build
up so we're not excluding the
possibility that they build up we're
just saying that in our formal and in
this formalism we don't allow the
electrons to build up in the wires so
for the purpose of the wires current and
E's equals recurrent out the net current
in is zero so we will think then about
the circuit having nodes the nodes are
the places where the elements where more
than one element meets two or more
elements meet and we will apply KCl at
each node so for example in this simple
circuit where I would have three parts
connected in what we would
all parallel they share a node at the
top and they share a note at the bottom
so even though it looks like there's
multiple interconnects up here we say
that's one node and we would say that
the sum of the currents into the node is
equal to the sum of the currents out so
if I labeled all of the possible
currents that come out of that node I
would have a I 1 I 2 I 3 I 1 goes
through the first one the second one the
third one and so I would conclude from
Kirchhoff's current law that the sum of
i1 i2 and i3 is zero okay easy
right as I said we're gonna make an
abstraction where the electrons don't
build up in the wires
they don't even build up in the parts
they do get stored in the parts of the
little confusing we'll come back to that
if they don't build up in the parts then
the current that goes in this leg has to
come out that leg if that's true then I
1 is I for I 2 is I 5 i3 is i6 and we
end up with another equation down here
which turns out to be precisely the same
as the one at the top okay everybody's
happy with that so we're thinking about
this just the way we would think about
water flowing if there's water flow into
a part it better be coming out if
there's water flow in a pipe the water
that goes into the pipe better come out
of the pipe someplace so here's an
arbitrary network made out of four parts
how many linearly independent KCl
equations are there
so how many linearly independent KCl
equations are in that Network we're
gonna raise your hand some number of KCl
equations okay as seeing a bigger
variety I see ones twos and threes I
don't see any fours that's probably good
so how do you think about the number of
linearly independent KCl equations all
of these so you have to have reference
directions before you can sort of think
about things so we have four elements we
would be expecting to see four element
currents the same current that goes into
an element has to come out of it
so there's element current one two three
and four there are three nodes so we
might be expecting three KCl equations
here's one node from which you would
conclude that the sum of i1 and i2
better be zero here's a node from which
you would conclude that the current in I
two better be i3 plus i-4 and here is a
node from which you would conclude that
i1 plus three plus four is zero so I can
write one KCl equation for every node
that's not surprising but if you look at
those equations you'll see that they're
not linearly independent in fact if you
solve this one for i2 it's already
solved for I to stick that answer up
here you get I three plus i-4 added to
i1 and zero which is just the same as
that equation so the there's of those
three equations only two of them are
linearly independent - the answer to
that problem was two and there's a
pattern so think about the pattern in
terms of figuring out the number of
linearly independent KCl equations or in
a slightly more complicated Network
so what's the answer here how many how
many KCl equations are in this network
Wow Wow not getting any of the answers I
would have said that what does that mean
hmm ah I'm forgetting to add tool that's
my problem okay now I'm getting some of
the issues that I would expect to get
okay got it I confused myself okay the
vast majority say 1 how do you get that
which is 3 in this circuit there are 4
nodes ABCD so we can think about writing
a KCl equation for each one if we go to
a a has 3 currents coming out of it 1 2
3 so the sum of those has to be 0 etc
and if you think about those equations
they're not many or the independents
either if you work through the math you
see that there's exactly one of those
equations that you can eliminate so
you're left with three linearly
independent KCl equations and so there's
a pattern emerging here somebody see the
pattern 1 - can somebody prove the
pattern so there's a pattern here the
pattern is take the number of nodes and
the number of independent KCl equations
is 1 less so the challenge is can you
prove it and by the theory of lectures
yes
and by a corollary of the theory of
lectures the way you would prove it is
I'm the next slide exactly so how do I
prove it yeah is to sort of generalize
the way we think about KCl so we start
with a circuit we think about having
four nodes here it's certainly the case
that KCl holds for each node so here's
KCl for that node but now if you think
about KCl for this node and then add the
one that looks like a KCl equation but
it applies to a super node imagine the
node defined by the black box and think
about the net currents into or out of
the black node this current i2 which
leaves the red node enters the green
node but doesn't go through the surface
of the black node at all that's exactly
the current that subtracted out when we
added the red equation to the green
equation does that make sense
so KCl says oh if all of the currents at
a node have to sum to zero and if
elements have the same current coming
out and going in then if you draw a box
around an element what goes into the
element is the same as what comes out of
the element it doesn't change the net
current through the surface so the
generalization of the KCl equation KCl
says the sum of the currents into a node
is zero the generalization says take any
closed path in a circuit
the sum of the currents going across
that closed path is zero so if we apply
that rule again think about node three
if we add the result of node three to
the black node which was the sum of one
and two we get the new green curve we
get the new green equation and what that
says is some of the currents going
across the green super node okay so
what's going on the I ones coming out of
it I four is coming out of it i five is
coming out of it so the sum of i1 four
and five has to be zero so the
generalization of KCl is that well KCl
says the sum of the currents coming out
of a node must be zero the super KCl
says the sum of the currents coming out
of any closed region is also zero but
the interesting thing about this closed
region is that it encloses all but one
of the nodes that's always true
regardless of the system regardless of
the circuit you can always draw a line
that will isolate one node from all the
others so what that proves is that you
can always write KCl for this node in
terms of KCl for those nodes okay
so there's a generalization then that
says that you can always write KCl for
every node they will always be linearly
dependent so you can always throw away
one so in some sense now we're done
we've just finished circuit theory we
talked about how every element has to
have a law a resistor is Ohm's law a
voltage source says that the voltage
across the terminals is always a
constant a current source says that the
current through the current source is
always a constant so every element tells
you one law I we know how to think about
KVL so we know the rule for how the
across variables
behave what's the aggregate behave
all the across variable as well KVL has
to be satisfied for every possible loop
the loops don't have to be independent
you have to worry about whether they're
independent the only simple rule we came
up with will come up with another one in
a moment there any simple rule that we
came up with was for planar circuits
where the innermost loop swirl in a
linearly independent of each other
and you have to write KCl for all the
nodes except one right one one of them
never matters
so in some sense we're done what we
would do to solve the circuit think
about every element for every element a
sign of voltage a reference voltage for
every element assign a current make sure
they go in the right direction
we always define currents to go down the
potential gradient they always go in the
directions through the element from the
positive to the negative so for every
element assign a current and a voltage
we have six elements that's 12 equate
that's 12 unknowns now we dig and refine
12 equations in this particular circuit
we found those 12 equations there were
three KCl equations one for each of the
inner loops there were three KCl
equations one for each node except one
there were five Ohm's law equations one
for each one of the resistors there was
one source equation for the voltage
source twelve equations 12 unknowns were
done the only problem is a lot of
equations right it's not a very
complicated circuit we've only got six
elements I told I tried to motivate this
in terms of studying networks that had
10 to the 10 to the ninth elements right
this technique is not particularly great
at 10 to the ninth it would probably
work but we would probably be interested
in finding simpler ways so there are
simpler ways you might imagine and we'll
discuss two of them just very briefly
the dumb way that I just talked about is
what we call primitive variables element
variables if you write all the element
variables v1 v2 v3
for v5 v6 all the element currents i1 i2
i3 i-4 i-5 i6 write all the equations
you can solve in however if you're
judicious you can figure out a smaller
number of unknowns and a correspondingly
smaller number of equations one method
is called the node method when we're
thinking about the individual element
the thing that matters is the voltage
across the element however that's not
the easy way to write the circuit
equations a much easier way is not to
tell me the voltage across an element
but instead tell me the voltage
associated with each of the nodes if I
tell you the voltage associated with
every node the important thing about
that way of defining the variables is
that you're guaranteed that from those
variables you can tell me the voltage
across every part so for example in this
circuit this voltage source so if I call
this one ground will always have a magic
node called ground it is not special in
the least it's just the reference
voltage I'll come back to that I'll say
it words in a minute about what the
reference is we always get to declare
one node to be ground if we get one free
node it's a node whose voltage we don't
care about because it's the reference
for all voltages
it's a node whose current we don't care
about because we get to throw away one
node when we do current equations so we
have one special node called ground
about which we don't care too much
except that it's the most important node
in the circuit except for that we don't
care about it so so this guy's ground we
think about its voltage being zero then
this voltage supply makes that node be V
naught I don't know what that is so I'll
call it e one that I don't know what
that is so i'll call it e 2 so if I tell
you the voltage on all of those nodes
grounds voltage is zero the top voltage
is V naught the left voltage is e 1 the
right voltage is e 2 from those four
numbers zero and three non-trivial
numbers you can find all of the
component voltages so for the example
the voltage v6 the voltage across our
six is e2 minus e1 the voltage V for the
voltage across the r4 resistor is e1
minus zero so if I tell you all the node
voltages you can tell me all of the
element voltages and in general there's
fewer nodes than there are components
okay that's great right so instead of
naming the volts across the elements
we'll name the voltages at the nodes
because as fewer of them then all we
need to do in the node method is write
the minimum number of KCl equations we
know we only have two unknowns a1 and e2
and it turns out and you can prove this
but I won't prove it today it turns out
that you need two KCl equations right
two unknowns e1 e2 2 KCl equations and
it turns out those 2 KCl equations are
exactly the KCl equations associated
with the two nodes so the current
leaving a 1 so KCl at e1 well there's a
current that goes that way well that's
the voltage drop in going from e1 to V
naught V 1 minus V naught divided by R 2
that's Ohm's law so this term represents
the current going up that leg plus the
current that goes through this leg which
is e1 minus e2 over R 6 plus the current
going in that leg which is e1 minus 0
over R 4 the sum of those three currents
better be 0 and alig ously the sum of
the currents at this node must be 0 and
the equation looks virtually the same
because V naught is known so they didn't
add an unknown V V naught was set by the
voltage by the voltage source
so I have two equations two unknowns
solved done so rather than solving
twelve equations in 12 unknowns I can do
it with two equations and two unknowns
that's called the node method one of the
most interesting theories about circuits
is that every simplification that you
can think about for voltage has an
analogous simplification that you can
think about in current that's called
duality we're going to do that because
it's kind of complicated but it's kind
of a cute result if you can think of a
simplification that works in both each
then there is an analogous one and you
can prove it in fact you can formally
derive what it must have been so the
this is a rule for how you can simplify
things by thinking about voltages in
aggregate rather than thinking about the
element voltages think about the node
voltages the analogous current law is
rather than thinking about the currents
through the elements the element
currents think about loop currents okay
that's a little bizarre
so we name the loop the current that
flows in this loop ia the current that
flows in this loop IB and the current
that flows in this loop I see what on
earth is he doing well the element
voltages are some linear combination of
those loop currents and in fact the
coefficients in the linear combination
are 1 and minus 1 so the element current
I for the current that flows through the
r4 resistor is the sum of ia coming down
- IC which is going up so there's a way
of thinking about each element current
as a sum or difference of the loop
currents everybody get that so instead
of thinking about the individual element
currents I think about the loop currents
and now I need to write three KVL
equations right so in the node method in
the node method I named the nodes and
had to write two KCl equations here I
name the loop currents and I have to
write three
KVL equations one for each loop it's
completely analogous if you write out a
sentence what did you do I assigned the
voltage to every node and I wrote KCl at
all the nodes then if you turn the word
current into the word voltage the word
node into the word loop you derived this
new method so this says that if I write
KVL at the a loop
think about spinning around this loop as
I go up through the voltage source and
so I go in the negative terminal here so
that's minus V naught as I go down
through this resistor I have to use
Ohm's law so that's R two times the down
current well the down current is ia down
minus IB up so I went up through here
down through here and now I go down
through this one when I go down through
that one that's the RF according to
Ohm's all that's our four times the
current through that element that
current well it's I a down and it's IC
up so this is the the KVL equation for
that loop I write two more of them and I
end up with three equations and three
unknowns both the node method and the
loop method resulted in a lot fewer
equations then the primitives did write
I had 12 primitive unknowns six voltages
and six currents in the node method I
get the number of independent nodes as
the number of equations and unknowns
which is less than the number of
primitive variables in the loop method I
had the number of independent loops
which is again smaller so the idea then
is that we have a couple of ways to
think about solving circuits
fundamentally all we have are the
element relationships and the rules for
combination no this is starting to sound
like pecan primitives and combinations
so the primitives are how does the
element constrain the voltages and
currents we know three of those Ohm's
law voltage source current source and
what are the rules for combination
well the currents added a node and the
voltages add around loops okay just to
make sure you've absorbed all that
figure out the current I for this
circuit
okay what's a good way to start what
should I do to start thinking about
calculating I okay bad way assigned
voltages and currents to everything four
elements that's four voltages for
currents that's eight unknowns find
eight equation and solve that'll work
bad way what's a better way you won
eight primitive variables
eighth birthday variables are what I
love me to I reach 3 I 3 V 4 I 4 right
so that's what I mean by a primitive
variables right sure or element
variables there's another word for it
what's a better way than using element
variables around here then I one is
actually I right and if you do I to
going around here what's I to so if I
think about I to spinning around this
loop so the sum of i1 and i2 goes
through that box but the only current
that goes through this box is
sorry I have I was here but I know
that's I then I can see immediately
since the only current that goes through
here so I have I 1 and I 2 that was a
very clever idea if you have I want an
IQ the only current that goes through
here is I so I one must have been I the
only current that goes over here must
have been this guy so this must be minus
10 right so I could redo that this way I
could say I've got 10 going that way
that makes sense so now I only have one
unknown which is I right so that's a
very clever way of doing it so what I
could do is showed here right I have I
going around one loop and I have 10
going around that loop that completely
specifies all the currents so now all I
need to do is write KVL for these
different cases right
so if I write KVL for the left loop then
I get going up through here that's minus
15 and going down through here going to
the right through this guy is 3 I going
down through this guy is 2 times I my
plus 10
both of these are going down so I have
to add them so I get one equation in one
unknown and when I saw what I get minus
one that make sense there's an analogous
way you could have done it with one node
you could have said that the circuit has
a single node and and figured out KCl
for that one node KCl would be the sum
of the currents here there's a current
that goes that way that way in that way
and again you end up with one equation
and one unknown yes
correct so not how right if I thought
about this current going this way it
would be minus 10 if I flip the
direction then it's plus 10 so the loop
current the loop current has the
property that it's the only current
through this element so that has to
match it's one of two currents that go
through this element so if I'm doing it
with loops right I have two loops the
current through this element is just I
the current through this element is just
I the current through this element is
just ten the current through this
element well the sum of these two
currents go through that element that
makes sense
and contributes to this element but so
does that one okay if you're still
confused kind you should try to get it
straightened out in one of the software
labs or the hardware lab or talk to me
after lecture but the idea is to
decompose in the case of the node
voltages think about the element
voltages in terms of differences in the
node voltages in the case of the loop
currents think about the element
currents in terms of a sum of loop
currents okay so the answer is minus one
regardless of how you do it okay the
remaining thing I want to do today is
think about abstraction we've talked
about the primitives which are things
like resistors voltage sources and
current sources means of combinations
that's KVL and KCl now we want to think
about abstraction and the first
abstraction that we'll talk about is how
do you think about one element that
represents more than one element this is
the same thing that we did when we
thought about linear systems when we did
signals and systems we started with ours
and Cays and pluses and we made single
boxes that had lots of ARS and pluses
and gains in them right what was the
name of the thing that was inside the
box if we combine lots of ours gains and
pluses into a single box what would be
called the thing that's in the Box shout
again system function right so we we
started with boxes that only had things
like ours in them but eventually we got
boxes that looked like much more
complicated things like that
we thought about a system function which
was a generalized box they could have
lots of ours or lots of games or lots of
pluses in it and that was a way of
abstracting complicated systems so they
look like simple systems what we want to
do here is the same thing for circuits
we want to have a single element a
single circuit element that represents
many circuit elements in the simplest
case of that is for series and parallel
combinations of resistors it's very
simple to think about how if you had 2
ohms law devices connected in series you
could replace those two with a single
resistor and the voltage current
relationships measured at the outside of
the box would be the same that's how we
think about an abstraction in circuits
when is it that you can take a circuit
when is it that you can draw a box
around a piece of a circuit and think
about that as one element the very
simplest case is the series combination
of two resistors same sort of thing
happens for the parallel combination and
that simple abstraction makes some
things very easy think what would be the
equivalent resistance for a complicated
system like that well that's easy all
you need to do is think about
successively reducing the pieces here
I'm thinking about that having four
resistors I can just successively apply
series in parallel in order to reduce
that make it less complicated so I can
think about combining these two in
series to get instead of two one ohm
resistors one two ohm resistor then I
can think about these two two ohm
resistors being equivalently one
parallel one ohm resistor and so this
whole thing looks as though it's just 2
ohms from the outside world that's what
we mean by an abstraction what we're
trying to do and what we will do over
the next two weeks is we'll think about
ways of combining circuits so that we
can reduce the complexity this way
another convenient way of thinking about
reducing the work that you need to do is
to think about common patterns that
result please see AP right primitives
combinations abstractions so the series
and parallel idea was an abstraction a
pattern here's a common pattern if
you've got two resistors in series if
the same current flows through two
resistors then there's a way of very
simply calculating the voltage that
falls across each right so you can think
about the some resistor our 1 plus r2
since they're in series so that allows
you then to compute the current from the
voltage then the voltage that falls
across this guy is by Ohm's law just the
current times its resistor which is like
that and similarly with this one so you
can see that some fraction of this
voltage V occurs across the v1 terminal
and some different fraction appears
across the v2 terminal such that the sum
of the fractions is of course V right
that's what has to happen for the tool
and there's a proportional drop the
bigger r1 the bigger is the proportion
of the voltage that falls across r1 so
it's a simple way of thinking about how
voltage drops across two resistors
there's a completely analogous way of
thinking about how current splits
between two resistors here the the
result looks virtually the same except
it has kind of the unintuitive property
that most of the current goes through
the resistor that is the smallest so you
get a bigger current in I 1 in
proportion to the r2 right so it works
very much like the voltage case except
that it has this inversion in it that
the current likes to go through the
smaller resistor okay so last problem
using those kinds of ideas
think about how you could compute the
voltage v-0 and determine what's the
answer
so what's the easy way to think about
this answer what do i do first
this becoming that you think about the
parallel becoming that you get a simple
divided by two voltage divider so the
answer is seven and a half which was the
middle answer and so what I what we did
today was basically a whirlwind tour of
the theory of circuits and the goal for
the rest of the week is to go to the lab
and do the same sort of thing with
practical where you build a circuit and
try to use some of these ideas to
understand what it does